Oh,
who does?
I'm against poverty.
You know,
that's like classic protest sign.
It's like,
really?
It's like I'm against torture.
It's like,
it's so obvious you don't get any Brownie points for being against poverty.
No one in their right mind is for poverty.
Okay.
You know what?
You ever watched the Simpsons?
You ever see the,
the Republican Party in the Simpsons,
they all meet in an old haunted castle at night with like lightening bolts going
off and there's a vampire and a crazy tax.
And then even the Simpson Republicans don't sit around in the haunted tower at
midnight saying the way we need more poverty.
Okay,
here's an interesting thing.
So one of the postmodernist claims is that diversity is necessary and they make
it racial and they make it sexual.
They may get ethnic and all of that.
That's actually technically incorrect by the way,
because
yeah,
I study individual differences.
So those are the differences between people.
No,
no,
no.
The literature.
So you know about James Tomorrows memo right from Google.
He wrote that partly because he was watching my videos,
which is why he wanted me to interview him.
And I'm a believer that there are biological differences in temperament between
men and women,
apart from the other obvious differences and that they're actually not trivial.
Okay.
And that they maximize in the societies that have the most,
have moved farther as to producing egalitarian states,
Scandinavian countries,
and that the reason for that is that there's two reasons why men and women,
different temperament.
One is biological and the other is environmental.
And if you remove the environmental variation,
which you do,
if you make the state egalitarian,
you maximize the genetic variation.
And that's been demonstrated in the scientific literature over about four
decades and no one wanted it or hope for it.
And they weren't biased in looking for it because that was exactly the opposite
of what social scientists wanted to find.
Because social scientists lean heavily to the left and what they wanted to find
was you flatten out the state so that everyone has equal opportunity and the
differences between people disappear.
That is not what happened.
The opposite happened that wasn't wrong and no one was happy about it and no
one's happy about it.
Now you can actually tell when you've discovered something in the social science
cause you're not happy about it.
But
if you take,
let's say there's a big difference between men and women in terms of trait,
agreeableness,
compassion and politeness.
On average,
women are more agreeable than men.
And the difference is approximately this.
If you random pairs of men and women out of the population,
let's say you had to make a bet on who was more agreeable.
If you bet that it was the woman,
you'd be right 60% of the time.
Well that's not that much.
It means you'd be wrong 40% of the time.
That's almost 50% of the time.
So this is a big difference by social science standards,
but that's the magnitude of the difference.
There are some differences that are bigger,
like the difference between men and women's interest in people versus things is
actually bigger than that.
That's the biggest difference we know,
but it's a big difference.
Let's say the agreeable this difference,
but still they,
the shared attributes of men and women far outweigh the attributes that
differentiate them.
Because you could ask are there more differences within groups or between them?
Now the postmodern answered that is between them.
That's why you need diversity by group,
right?
That's why you need different races.
That's why you need different ethnicities and sexual preferences and all of
that.
Well,
that's wrong.
There's more difference within the groups than there is between them.
You don't get diversity by crossing the groups.
You'd get diversity by,
by selecting across individuals.
In fact,
the idea that there is more differences between groups and there is between
individuals is actually the fundamental racist idea.
It's the fundamental racist idea,
which is,
well,
let's say you're
Asian Oriental,
to use the old word to discriminate
the one type of Asian say from the other.
You're so different from me that there's no overlap between our groups and
you're all so different and there's so little difference within your group that
now that I know that you're not me,
you're not one of mine.
I actually know what you're like.
No,
technically that's incorrect.
That's wrong.
That isn't how you get diversity.